it's been called The Forgotten genocide
and the Armenian Holocaust by some
others say it was just the inhumane
consequences of war but no matter what
you call it one thing we know is true
two million Armenians were living in the
Ottoman Empire at the start of World War
one and by 1922 up to 1.5 million had
been killed but even that number is
disputed so why all the controversy well
for starters modern-day turkey doesn't
like the word genocide it claims there
was no official policy of extermination
against the Armenian people and that
hundreds of thousands of people died in
the region during World War one
President Barack Obama has referred to
it as a horror but American presidents
who want to keep turkey as a strategic
ally in the region have historically not
used the term genocide same with the UN
so what exactly happened well 100 years
ago the Ottoman Empire the ancestral
homeland of Armenians was crumbling the
government of The Young Turks began to
paint the minority Christian Armenians
as a threat to the state as some
Armenians had sided with Russia at the
start of World War one Armenians marked
the beginning of the massacre or
medicean as April 24th 1915 when
hundreds of Armenian intellectuals were
arrested and later executed from that
moment on there were mass killings of
hundreds of thousands of Armenian
in the region the Turkish authorities
ordered the forced deportations of the
Armenian people mostly to the Syrian
desert during these death marches the
Armenians faced rape robbery food
deprivation and murder by Arab or
Kurdish tribes along the way those who
survived the marches ended up in
concentration camps
the American ambassador at the time
wrote in his memoir when the Turkish
authorities gave the orders for these
deportations they were merely giving the
death warrant to a whole race the event
has often been referred to as the first
genocide of the 20th century by the end
of the war a huge portion of the
Armenian population had been killed many
of the survivors fled to the Russian
Empire and in 1918 an independent
Armenian Republic was established today
it is the Republic of Armenia an
independent country but because of the
massacre the Armenian diaspora extends
throughout the world